MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Please give
a warm welcome to Kino Kimino.
[APPLAUSE]
KIM TALON: Thanks, Matthew.
[MUSIC - KINO KIMINO]
[APPLAUSE]
You guys are so polite.
Does anybody bad work here?
Like, are there
any bad kids here?
You guys are just--
[LAUGHTER]
I could tell, like, there's
one bad person that I
saw while we were playing.
I think it's you, and it's
not because you're just
standing right in front of me.
Um, OK.
[MUSIC - KINO KIMINO]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
We're going to
play one more song.
And I feel like now I
must be really feeling
the rebelliousness of Google,
because my guitar string broke
and that never happens.
SPEAKER 1: You're the bad woman.
KIM TALON: What?
SPEAKER 1: Now
you're the bad girl.
KIM TALON: Now I'm the bad girl.
[MUSIC - KINO KIMINO]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Please
help me welcome back
to the stage, Kim Talon.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks so much for
joining us here.
KIM TALON: Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Great performance.
Really enjoyed it.
KIM TALON: Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Fantastic stuff.
The new album is called
"Bait for Sissies."
KIM TALON: "Bait
Is for Sissies."
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
"Bait IS for Sissies."
What does that mean?
KIM TALON: Oh, you're going
to ask me that question?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I am going
to ask you that question.
It's a good place to start.
KIM TALON: Well, I suppose the
simplified answer-- otherwise
we could have a conversation
for a couple of hours about it.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well, it
is called Talks at Google.
KIM TALON: It comes
down to maybe not making
the courageous
choice, I suppose.
So there's the literal
definition of bait,
and then there's what we
would consider to be bait.
I'm not explaining
this very well.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: People bait?
KIM TALON: Yeah, people bait.
That's exactly what
I'm talking about.
Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: OK.
KIM TALON: This is a
little early for us,
so my mind's not--
I haven't talked to that
many people yet today.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Sure, sure, no problem.
So Kino Kimino-- is
it accurate to say
this is the third notable
project that you've
put your energy behind?
KIM TALON: Yes.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
But you've been
grinding away for many years--
KIM TALON: Yes.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: --a decade
or more in the Indie scene,
or Independent scene.
KIM TALON: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Do
you find a difficulty
in the nomenclature of that,
like Indie versus Independent?
Do you get people
who are like, hey,
you know, you've worked
with bigger named people,
or bigger named artists.
You're not independent
any anymore,
but you still fit
in Indie as a genre.
KIM TALON: Well, first of all,
I don't hear the word "Indie"
that much anymore.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I
think it's better that way.
You probably shouldn't.
KIM TALON: So that's nice.
But you know, I think all
the projects I've done
are so underground in a way
that, like what you're saying,
can I be Indie if I'm
not really Independent?
Well, I really am
pretty Independent
and have always been.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well, and I think
it shows a lot in terms of the
sort of multimedia approach
to yourself as an artist.
It's not all in on the
music-- you guys also
spend a great deal
of time creating
these videos for all the
songs, like what we just saw.
And there's a lot of
artistic creativity
that is channeled in
that direction as well.
What motivates you to sort of
dabble in all of these mediums?
KIM TALON: Lack
of label support.
I mean, I would hire out
people to make videos and do
all the other parts that
musicians have to do--
band pictures, or just
all the media part of it.
But I just never
had full support
from a record label the
way that I would like to.
So it's kind of just like,
what could I do with my iPhone?
What can I do with
my friend who's over?
Like, what can we make that
doesn't cost a lot of money?
That kind of thing.
So you know, like sometimes
they say lack of resources
sometimes leads to
the most creative--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Necessity
is the mother of invention.
KIM TALON: Yeah, yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
OK, that's great.
How long ago was it when
you made the transition
from California here
to New York City?
KIM TALON: It's
been a few years.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
The reason why
I ask is because I know as being
an artist and musician as well
in the Brooklyn scene and having
been doing that for the past 10
years, I've seen a
lot of evolution.
So I'd like to talk about the
evolution that you've seen--
the differences between what
it was like out in California
and then coming here.
And it triggered in me this
morning, I remembered a quote,
and I think it was 2010, Patti
Smith said that if she could
give advice to young artists who
wanted to move to New York City
to really dive into their art,
her advice would be don't.
Don't go to New York City,
in the thinking that New York
City's done, or
it's over-saturated,
or it's just not the place.
KIM TALON: Well, it's
certainly over-saturated.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well,
let's talk about that.
So you came from another--
that whole LA-Southern
California scene
is also wildly over-saturated
with independent music.
KIM TALON: Yeah, but
not to the same degree.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: In what way?
KIM TALON: There's less bands.
I feel kind of bad saying this,
because I love Los Angeles.
And maybe it's just my
personal experience,
but I've seen a higher
quality here of--
I wouldn't say musicianship,
but a lot of the bands
are working really hard and
writing really good songs.
Maybe it's just more
my taste, I think.
New York, the sound
here or in Brooklyn
is a little more gritty.
And in LA there was
a lot of music around
that was a little too
pretty for my taste.
So it could just be a
personal preference.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Sure, but
that grit sort of comes out.
It definitely comes out in
the sound and in the music.
And a lot of people who
have talked about your work
before or reviewed
the music before,
they tend to fall into this
vein of common adjectives,
things like relating it to
the whole Riot Grrl stuff.
Indie gets thrown around a lot.
Grunge gets thrown around a lot.
And I think that that's probably
lazy writing a lot of the times
more than anything else,
but how much of that
adjective stuff do
you self-ascribe,
versus how much of it do
you find is just laid on you
and you don't have
much exit from?
KIM TALON: I think it's
the same kind of thing
like when people talk
about you, or people
say you're a nice person,
you're a this kind of person,
or you're that kind of person.
You don't really think about
the way people think of you
unless you're a weirdo, I guess.
So, like, for me, I don't
really think too much
about what people say.
It's not that I'm
past that, or I
don't pay attention, or
get offended or happy when
people say good or bad things.
It's just that it really plays
no role in my consciousness.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Interesting.
So let's dive a little bit
deeper into the Brooklyn scene.
You guys have done a
lot of playing around
out there with a lot
of local level talent.
And you said you find bands that
are just fighting, fighting,
fighting to get any sort of--
carve out their
land on the ground.
Do you find that
that motivates you
more to keep pace with that?
Is it overwhelming
at times as a band
doing everything yourself to see
all these people who are maybe
accomplishing more and or less,
or doing less and seemingly
accomplishing more?
KIM TALON: Well, there's
a couple of things.
First of all, I lead a
pretty isolated life.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Difficult to do in this city.
KIM TALON: My choosing.
I think I'm a little
over-stimulated by the city.
And my reaction to it is to
sort of not go out too much,
and just write at home
and stuff like that.
And then the other
part of it is,
there's so many bands,
that to feel affected
by the climate of
all of that, you'd
have to really be paying
attention, and I'm not.
I'm not really that interested.
I'm interested, and I love
going to see bands that I like.
But I'm not--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It's
difficult to really cut
through--
KIM TALON: I'm not interested in
the sociological aspect of it,
I suppose.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Yeah, it's strange,
the sort of divisions of
pie that Brooklyn has.
I find these genre
kids group off
in this direction and
play in these venues
with these other bands.
And these communities
are supportive
inside their community, but
isolative of each other.
KIM TALON: Yeah.
I mean, now that I think
about it a little more
and think about my detachment,
there is one part of it
that I am interested
in and that I
have been paying attention to,
and that is the female aspect.
Because I've always loved
playing with female musicians,
and I love listening
to female artists.
And I don't know why, but I just
have always been drawn to that,
and I love female bands.
And when I moved to
Brooklyn, I realized, wow,
there's so many more all-female
bands compared to Los Angeles.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah.
KIM TALON: And I'm
sure all over the world
there's more women doing
all kinds of things,
but that's one thing
that I notice here.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Again,
maybe it's something
to do with the concentration
that that stuff shows up?
KIM TALON: Yeah, I mean,
there's a lot of people here.
There's also a
lot of women here.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Hopefully, about half.
KIM TALON: I think it's a
little bit more than half.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Hey,
more than half sounds great.
Let's go back to the
album for a minute.
So "Bait Is for Sissies," you
had some very interesting help
in the production and
recording of the record,
that in the form of Lee
Ranaldo and Steve Shelley
from Sonic Youth.
How did that
relationship come to be,
and how did the efforts
to get this album made
play out with those two?
KIM TALON: Yeah.
So, it was interesting
to me as well.
So basically I had
spoken with this producer
named John Agnello years
ago about making a record.
But I was still
on the west coast
and I just couldn't pull it
together to come over here.
But I really wanted
to work with him.
He's an amazing guy.
And then when I came
to New York to live,
I called him and we
talked on and off
about making a record together.
And he was asking me who I
wanted to use for the record.
And I was kind of at a
loss, because I'd always
played with my friends in LA and
I did not know many musicians
in New York at all.
So we kind of joked
around, and the idea
of using some of the Sonic
Youth guys was thrown out there.
And John was like, OK,
well, give me your demos
and I'll send them
over to those guys.
And if you guys only knew
how horrible my demos are.
I recorded them on my bed.
I'm just not great
at recording at all--
and then for some reason,
like, 10 backup vocal tracks,
and stuff like that.
But I guess they liked them.
I was very happy.
I called my mom right
away and was like,
the guys from Sonic
Youth liked my bad demos.
And then it just kind
of evolved from there.
It happened really quickly.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Do you
find that working with them
changed the process for you?
You talked a bit about
recording bad demos
and approaching it that
way, and then the DIY
background of your music.
In this situation
now where we're
bringing in really
established players,
I'm sure it was a great
studio environment
that you were able to
work in with the producer.
Did you find that there
were impacts to the way
that you would go through
the process because of that?
Were you more
conscious about the way
you were making things
sound or making decisions
because these legends
were in the room?
Or did it play out just like,
oh yeah, some nice guys that
are here to play some songs?
KIM TALON: Yeah.
Well, a couple things.
Well, first of all, the
main difference that
comes to mind when you
ask that question is we
didn't use a click
for the drums.
And I had always
recorded with a click
because I suppose I didn't
feel confident enough
to go off the click.
So that was one difference.
And then, obviously,
I felt nervous.
I'd been listening to
Sonic Youth forever.
But it was weird.
And that's the weird
thing about music
for me is it just seems
like another limb to me.
And I should have
felt more intimidated,
and I think I should have felt
more scared, but I didn't.
And actually for one or two of
the days, John, our producer,
had to go out of town and I
had to produce the [? Lee ?]
days, which you can
imagine I was like--
But he was really sweet.
And he was like, OK,
what do you want?
What do you want on this chorus?
What do you want on this verse?
And I feel really
comfortable producing,
because I've done it a lot
and I actually love producing.
So it actually gave me way
more creative freedom, at least
for that part of the record,
to really experiment and play
around.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Nice.
And now that the record is out--
KIM TALON: Yeah, it
came out in June.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Yeah.
The plans to push
and promote, I know
you guys have maybe a couple
of local things coming up,
but we're looking at
maybe winter touring?
KIM TALON: Yeah.
So we're going to be doing a
tour around the Million Women
March.
They keep changing
the name of it,
so I don't know what
it's called today.
But anyways, we'll
be at the March
in D.C. And then
the night before
we're playing in Philadelphia,
and we're just organizing shows
around the March.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: So,
somewhere in the Northeast?
KIM TALON: Yeah, East Coast.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: For
people who have been watching
and saw the performance, if
you're not going very far west,
or maybe they're in
Europe, something
like that, where is a
good place for people
to be able to consume the
art that you guys have
been creating?
KIM TALON: Well, you can
go to KinoKimino.com,
and we're on
Facebook, Instagram.
I Twitter every once in a
while, but I don't really
know what to say.
What do musicians
say on Twitter?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Things to fill space.
KIM TALON: Right.
Yeah, that's not my forte,
but we are on Twitter.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I
think that's pretty much
what anyone says on
Twitter, just like,
oh, fill some silence.
KIM TALON: Yeah, we've got
a bunch of videos on YouTube
and you can buy the record
on Amazon iTunes, all that.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Let's
talk about the videos.
So there's a lot of things out
there, and one of the things
that I've noticed-- and it
carries over a little bit
to the music, but specifically
with the videos-- is it always
seems that there's one sort
of, like, "Where's Waldo"
element of like, find the
thing that's different.
Find the thing that stands out.
And I know that other people
have thrown the Dada movement
references, or Dada-ism,
into the mix as well.
Is that a conscious thing?
Or is that just, hey, this
would be a good idea to do
and it happens to
relate to that,
or other people perceive
it relating to that?
That's not a very
well-worded question, is it?
KIM TALON: I understand
what you're saying.
I would say it's just a result
of your parents raising you
without a filter.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: OK.
And do you find your
fans are attracted
to that stuff, relate
to that stuff, maybe
they miss that stuff?
How important is it as a
Kimino-ist in the world to key
in on those elements?
KIM TALON: That's an
interesting question.
I've never thought about that.
I think that an important
part of making art in any way
is just trying not to think
about your audience too much
and just doing what's
organic for you.
So when you are
asking me basically
are people getting this
stuff, or who's getting it,
or how important is that,
I don't really know.
It seems like some
people are getting it,
because people, at
least for this record,
have responded really nicely.
But I don't know.
Did I answer your question?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
A little bit.
KIM TALON: A little bit?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I
just wonder how much of it
is baked into--
art is two things.
Art is the artist's intention.
Art is what the viewer sees.
I wonder how much of
the tongue-in-cheek,
the comedic elements,
the Dadaist elements,
are baked in from your
intention, and how much of it
is just what the
audience is perceiving.
KIM TALON: Oh, no, no, no.
It's definitely what I'm doing.
It it's not perception.
I feel like in a lot of
ways it's selfishly probably
just to amuse myself maybe.
Or maybe it has something
to do with one of the songs,
or something like that.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Are
there plans for more videos?
KIM TALON: Well,
Jordan, our drummer, she
wants to make a video for
the song called "Bloodbath."
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: "Bloodbath."
So we'll keep an
eye out for that--
KIM TALON: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
--on the YouTube page.
We do want to open
it up for Q&A. So
if anyone in the
audience has a question,
please make your
way to a microphone.
While they're doing that,
can you take a moment
and introduce the band that
was here with us today?
KIM TALON: I'd love to.
So this is Jordan.
She plays drums.
That's Tara.
She's playing the
white guitar over here.
And that's Cindy,
and she plays bass.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And how did
you come together as a band?
KIM TALON: I think just through
each other and mutual friends.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
That Brooklyn scene?
KIM TALON: Yeah.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Excellent.
We do have a question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I
know in prior bands
you've collaborated
with other artists,
including Reggie
Watts and Alice Talon.
How did you get
together with them,
and what was that process like?
KIM TALON: How did I get
together with Alice and Reggie?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KIM TALON: So I met
Alice on Craigslist.
And I met Reggie at--
there's this weird jazz
band that was performing
at the House of Blues in LA.
They're really famous.
I feel bad now.
It's like some band related
to that band Lettuce--
like one of those
kind of jazzy, funky.
I don't know what
I was doing there.
I think I met Reggie
backstage at that show,
and then we just became friends.
And he'd stay with me when
he was in LA because he was
living in Brooklyn at the time.
And then we kind
of swapped places
and moved to opposite
coasts at the same time.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Let's go over here.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
where the "mashed potato"
line in "Passion" comes from.
KIM TALON: Oh, man,
that's a good question.
I think that it was like, I have
certainly gone through phases--
and this also happens to
me weekly and monthly--
of thinking that love and
romance is just ridiculous,
and my sort of romantic
leanings are equally ridiculous.
So just kind of like
passion is blank.
It's like mashed potatoes.
It's like, I don't
know, curtains.
It's wires on the floor.
Am I answering that?
Does that make sense?
OK.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
The mashed potatoes
is kind of a very
apparent moment of--
KIM TALON: I hate that mashed
potatoes are now becoming
like my international symbol.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Yeah, you got
to watch out for that stuff.
People will meme you so quickly.
What should it be?
If it's not "passion
is a mashed potato,"
what is the line that you would
like people to hang around?
KIM TALON: I think
you've got a good point.
Maybe we should
just leave it be.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Just run with it?
KIM TALON: Yeah.
You can't think of your
own nickname, right?
That's, like, not OK.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
So, future merch booths
at Kino Kimino shows--
t-shirts, vinyl, CDs,
mashed potatoes to go.
KIM TALON: I did for that
video you guys watched,
I had about seven boxes of--
have you guys seen those
dry mashed potatoes?
They come in boxes and
they blow up so much,
so we had so many
mashed potatoes.
And we were staying
at, like, a love hotel.
You know what I
mean by that, right?
Like, those hourly hotels.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: With,
like, the theme rooms, right?
KIM TALON: Right,
with the theme rooms.
So we had, like, a
sink full of mashed.
It was, like, such a mess.
I still have-- I don't know
what to do with those boxes.
I don't want to eat them.
Maybe I should have
them at my shows.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Yeah, there you go.
The struggles that we
go through for art.
Well, we thank you very much
for playing for us today
and for taking the
time to come and visit.
Again, you guys visit
KinoKimino.com, check them out
on YouTube, and look
for the tour this fall.
"Bait Is for Sissies"
is the new record.
Thank you once
again, Kino Kimino.
KIM TALON: Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]